Speaker 1: This is really one of the most
remarkable confrontations of a Republican
delusion that I've seen in a long time, and
it took place on Fox News, no doubt.
A Fox News host, Neil Cavuto, asked former
Republican Senator Kelly Lefler remember her
really the perfect question about her claims
that there were problems and irregularities
in the 2020 election in Georgia in which she
was a candidate and lost to Raphael Warnock.
And the question is really simple.
If there were problems with the Trump vs.
Biden results and they can't be trusted because
the Georgia secretary of state, Brad Raffensperger,
was a partizan and biased arbiter of that
election, he supported you, Kelly Lefler,
in that race.
What does that mean?
Isn't that an obvious conflict?
Now, remember that I brought this up, a similar
version of this back in November, just after
the election when I tweeted, quote, Why have
Trump and Republicans accepted the results
from House and Senate elections, but not presidential?
Everything was on the same ballots.
In other words, tons of Republicans who won
in the House and Senate on the same ballots
as where Trump lost were saying, we cannot
trust these results.
It's rigged.
This there's all sorts of irregularities.
But so hold on.
We also can't trust that you won.
Right.
And of course, that's not what they were talking
about, an obvious problem with their argument.
So let's now get to the video of Neil Cavuto,
who reduces Carly Lefler to mumbling and stumbling
by pointing out, you know, the guy you're
saying needs to be investigated for his role
in the election.
He supported you in that race.
And, of course, part of the implication here
is maybe he did something screwy to help you
as well.
Right.
Take a look at this.
Just a remarkable 60 seconds of footage making
sure that
Speaker 3: everyone's voice is heard.
Speaker 4: All right, so if we have an investigation
into that, it would be investigations after
other investigations, this one more focused,
I guess, on the behavior of Mr. Raffensperger.
But you would charge that you want to probe
into whether he used his office to advance
his political interests.
He was supporting you and your colleague.
So how was that opposite what your interests
were?
You were both on the same page.
Speaker 3: That's not exactly correct.
I mean, look, he's our top election official,
he's not a partizan official per say, but
Speaker 4: he wasn't for this, but he wasn't
for your opponent, right, Senator?
He was for you.
He was for Senator Purdue.
And what would be in his interest to sabotage
that?
Speaker 3: Not not suggesting sabotage, I'm
suggesting that Georgians don't trust voting
right now, and he took actions that led to
a lack of confidence.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Well, if Brad Raffensperger took actions that
led to a lack of confidence and he supported
Kelly Lefler, we should be looking into whether
Kelly Lefler really only lost by a little
bit to Raphael Warnock.
Maybe Kelly Lefler lost by a lot.
But Brad Raffensperger in the same way that
he may be pulled funny business against Trump
because he didn't like Trump.
This is their story.
Maybe he pulled some funny business in favor
of David Perdue and Kelly Lefler, who he supported.
Now, of course, what's the truth here?
The truth is, I think Kelly Lefler knows the
Georgia election was pretty fair.
Trump simply lost.
She has sort of played coy with all of this
stuff because remember that there was that
period between November and January where
Kelly Lefler and David Perdue were campaigning
for those special elections.
She was fighting for her political life between
November and January 5th, which was the day
of that special election.
And during that time, she needed Donald Trump's
support.
At least she believed she needed it.
I don't know, maybe it hurt more than helped.
So she was playing coy with the election fraud
stuff when she was asked directly whether
she agreed with Donald Trump that the election
in Georgia was rigged.
I think during the debate with Raphael Warnock,
it came up, she would say stuff like, well,
we need to investigate.
The president has every right to demand this
and that to his satisfaction that this was
done correctly and that was done correctly.
We need to ensure every vote, every legal
vote is counted and every voice is heard.
She was playing coy with it to avoid having
to say no.
I think Trump's telling UBS, but then that
risks losing the Trump support she thought
she needed in that special election in January.
I believe she doesn't care about Trump.
I think she cares about herself.
I think Kelly Lefler probably recognizes that
Trump's a disaster.
But if Trump is useful to her, if it helps
her win, then she'll say whatever and accept
Donald Trump's support.
She might want to run again.
And she's probably looking at the same polls
we're looking at, which show that at least
for right now, Donald Trump is a player in
Republican politics.
She might need Trump's help if she wants to
run again.
And she's going to keep playing coy and continuing
to be unable to just answer simple questions
are unable refusing to answer questions like
this one, which is, you know, the guy you're
saying we need to investigate supported you
in twenty twenty.
So where does that leave us with any of this
nonsense?
I was hoping that the last we'd see of Carly
Lefler was when she lost to Raphael Warnock
in January.
Appears not to be the case.
And she is truly detestable and so horrible
for the country and seems as determined as
ever to get involved again and to do more
damage.
You almost get the sense that Kelly Lefler
is like surprised she's being asked this question
on Fox, which I mean, listen, it's sort of
surprising.
But occasionally Neil Cavuto will ask what
we would call a real question that in other
countries, just every interview would have
real questions like this.
And she's asked a so-called real question,
and she's unable to string together anything
approximating a coherent response because
her position on this is and has been incoherent,
incoherent, like Trump.
She may run again and we will need to fight
her if that's indeed what happens.